a lot of that is all in the details
you've got to be into the details
because if you're not they'll come back
to haunt you so often life is in the
details well business also is in the
details you have to be very careful you
have to watch the dotted eyes because
you can really lose tremendously if you
don't watch those details it's all about
the details it's very important wanna be
totally focused you can't take your eye
off the ball when I had troubles in the
early 90s a major article came out and
it said very strongly everything he
touches turns to gold and I believed it
so I'd go out with models at night
instead of working but that wasn't good
and I remember I had a big lease coming
up and there was a big show and I went
to the show I said don't worry fellas
you can handle the least you'll get it
done well I came back they didn't get it
done and I would have had it done a
hundred percent and then the market
crashed in the 90s so I had trouble but
it was sort of an amazing I wouldn't
want to do it again it was an amazing
test of yourself
can you handle pressure how are you
under pressure are you smart you know
when when everybody's coming at you you
just watch - amazing clips from Donald
Trump take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how to apply
them to your business and your life
believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]